ein haufen adhs in center zusammen dass
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wusste dass dieser tag kommen wird
ich lebe seit 25 jahren auf diesem
planeten und habe europa noch nie
verlassen da ist es wohl das mindeste
dass mein erster flug eine super meister
business blog mit lounge wird ist also
los geht's heute ist jünger werden wir
nicht und wer zu spät kommt den bestraft
das leben
ich habe viel zu lange auf diesen moment
gewartet bin super aufgeregt und scheiß
mir vor freude fast in die hose
trigger warnung weit sie auch schon mal
einen langstreckenflug hinter sich
gebracht haben diesen aber in der
economy klasse verbringen mussten
dann tut es mir sehr leid die nächsten
bilder werden einen sehr sensiblen
inhalte darstellen denn die business
class ist absolut ober affengeil ich
habe mich so was von verdammt wohl
gefühlt das essen war absolut
fantastisch man konnte sich filme
anschauen
man konnte trinken bestehen essen
bestellen es gab zwischendurch kekse man
konnte sich hinlegen und schlafen und
diese acht stunden flug haben sich
einfach angefühlt wie drei maximum drei
vielleicht vier aber nicht mehr der zug
nach köln fühlt sich länger an als die
business class nach new york ok vanessa
übertreibt meine ich ja okay es war war
schon echt geil
und dann sind wir gelandet in der stadt
in der ich schon so oft ich meine
lieblingsfilme gelaufen bin
der ort wo harry sally getroffen hat und
wo das wunder von manhattan passiert ist
die stadt in der alles möglich ist new
york aber erstmal kommt kelly
sparmeister
[Musik]
oh mein gott die bestand laut
wieso
way
da kelly schon zweimal in new york war
übernahm sie natürlich die aufgabe des
reiseleiters und namens überall dorthin
wo sie schon mal war
wir sind jetzt hier im bekanntesten new
york
damit kehren
es ist sollte ohne plastik das konzept
dieses diners ist absolut carré sieht
denn die keller bringen die nicht nur
dein essen sondern singt auch
zwischendurch
[Applaus]
gleich ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diesmal gar nicht gut
was könnte das jetzt noch übertreffen
natürlich ein laden in dem 365 tage im
jahr weihnachtsartikel verkauft werden
[Musik]
ein aufschrei
bei einer
[Musik]
diese macht nicht
ich will alles kaufen will
die partie war eigentlich nichts mit ins
all
ich bin einfach auf sagt so früh sagen
und ich bin zwei mal derb haye
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vertritt mit ihr zu tun die dinge also
jeder von dem entfernt was hat eine
tolle figur und so ohne es zu ahnen sind
kelly und ich in unserem feuchten its
traum gelandet und es gab wirklich jeden
artikel auf der ganzen welt mit diesen
maskottchen drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nun was für jugendliche wanderzeit
zurück ins hotel zu gehen wenn durch die
zeitverschiebung hatten wir einen so
extrem langen dienstag und wir mussten
natürlich frisch und ausgeschlafen sein
für den morgigen tag
okay wir mache ich was vor wir sind
natürlich noch einen trinken gegangen
aber danach sei wirklich sofort ins bett
heute ist der große tag wir schauen uns
alle vor dem theater an und ist kelly
noch eine überraschung er zwei bts
puppen
ich stelle die so hin und dann menschen
die prangt groß mit ihren prinz
aufgehört haben na ja da muss hier
irgendwer weiter den quality konnten
aufrechterhalten nervous breakdown in
321 da hat kelly nicht ganz unrecht ich
sah wirklich verdammt schick aus und
während ich mir die frage gestellt habe
ob ich vielleicht nicht doch lieber
flache schuhe anziehen sollte kam auch
schon die neue shopping queen kandidatin
kelly um die ecke beide solche a promis
sind wollen wir natürlich mit dem
shuttle abgeholt julina und fabi waren
auch mit dabei und dann ging es auch
schon los
[Musik]
das theatergebäude sei von außen so
schön aus doch muss man natürlich erst
meine in story machen
ja
an diesem tag
wir haben morgen die welt geholt
für das theaterstück und jetzt dürfen
ist einfach noch in new york das ist
einfach ein traum
damit hast du so schön gesagt vanessa
wir berichten live aus dem broadway die
lupe
[Musik]
steinhaufen sei es entweder zusammen
du kriegst
[Musik]
das
ltd
[Musik]
nicht schlecht weil ich so aufgeregt bin
ja schon ein film wie durch eine million
mal aufgeregt bin ich und ich bin sehr
gespannt was für eine überraschung sind
auf uns wartet am time square dahin
[Musik]
egal
da ist das theaterstück ja schon in
london gesehen habe wusste ich natürlich
was mich erwartet und sind wieder so
begeistert von der magie auf der bühne
die story und den schauspielern es nimmt
einfach einen so wieder mit in diese
harry potter welt ich kann euch das
absolut empfehlen sich das auch in
london new york oder ab dem 22
märz in hamburg anzuschauen vielleicht
sieht man sich ja dort aber jetzt werden
wir erst mal zum times square entführt
[Musik]
wir müssen harte folgen
ich will ja lieber gerne kröten beugen
und dann passierte es obwohl wir so
viele kilometer von zu hause entfernt
sind wurden wir trotzdem angesprochen
und dann kam der große moment ich weiß
nicht genau wie das mit den
urheberrechten ist aber um auf nummer
sicher zu gehen werde ich erst jetzt
nach vertonen
denn den dienten
düren
[Musik]
gruselig alles wird dunkel harry potter
und last giants hurt jessica parker okay
einen clip mit sound werde ich euch
zeigen denn es war echt schon verdammt
cool
[Applaus]
nachdem kelly und ich dann noch ein rtl
interview gegeben haben ging es für uns
auch alle schon nach hause und
netterweise hat sie mit mir die schuhe
getauscht denn nach fünf stunden auf
hohen schuhen fühlt es sich an als ob
man dauerhaft auf leo laufen müsste
[Musik]